[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey
everyone, welcome to CE Chat,
hosted by Cloud OnAir,
where we host live webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Stephanie Wong,
Cloud Customer Engineer.
And today, we're back
again with Ryan Przybyl,
Cloud Customer Engineer
and networking specialist.
So today, we'll be talking
about networking 102.
Last time, we talked
about networking 101.
Today's topic is cloud
routing and VPC peering.
Just a quick note
for everyone, there
is a chance to ask live
questions on the Cloud OnAir
platform.
We will have Googlers answering
them live on the platform,
but we'll also save some time
at the end for any questions
that you might have outstanding.
So without further ado,
Ryan, take it over.
RYAN PRZYBYL: Thanks, Stephanie.
As Stephanie said, last time
we covered VPC, shared VPC,
and interconnect.
Today, we're going to
cover routing in the GCP
environment and VPC peering.
So when we talk about routing,
there's a whole bunch of ways
that routes get propagated
within the Google Cloud
Platform.
There are what we call
preprogrammed routes.
There is dynamic
routes, and there are
what we call advanced routes.
So I'm going to go
through each of those.
Preprogramed routes are what
we have when you set up a VPC,
and you create subnets.
These are routes
that get programmed
into allow VMs to talk to
other VMs within the VPC.
These are things that are
automatically created.
And these are also things that
you cannot delete or change.
Like I said, these
are the routes
that really allow a VM within
the VPC to talk to other VMs
within the VPC.
There is also default
routes that get created.
So the standard default
route that gets created
is going to point to
an internet gateway.
And a common question
that we get is, hey,
I have this default
route pointing
to an internet gateway.
Can my VMs talk to the internet?
So the answer to that is no,
not unless you put a public IP
address on that VM.
The difference between
the default routes
and the preprogrammed
routes is default routes
can actually be changed.
Like I said, the
default route that
will be created within
your cloud environment
actually points to
an internet gateway.
But let's say, for example, you
want the default route to point
back to your
on-prem environment.
Unlike the preprogrammed routes
for VM to VM communication,
you can actually go in and
change the default route.
A big part of understanding
dynamic routing
within the cloud
environment is actually
understanding the Cloud Router.
A Cloud Router is,
in a lot of ways,
very similar to a
traditional router
that you would have in
your on-prem environment.
But there are some
fundamental differences,
which I want to make sure
you guys really understand.
So in a typical data
center environment,
your router is going to be
a big piece of sheet metal.
It has dual power supplies.
It performs two real functions.
It provides control
plane functionality,
which is really the BGP route
communication mechanisms.
And it also provides
data point functionality.
That is packets go
into the router.
The router will look
up its RIBs and FIBs
and make routing decisions
and forward appropriately.
In the cloud environment,
the Cloud Router
is actually only a
control point device.
So packets that go into
your router on-prem,
they actually don't
go into the Cloud
Router in the GCP environment.
The Cloud Router functions as
a control plane only device.
And really, it learns routes
from your on-prem router
or from other routers in
the cloud environment.
You can really think about
it as a BGP speaker, right?
It only speaks BGP,
whereas your routers
that you may have on-prem may
speak other routing protocols.
This only speaks BGP.
So I want to make sure that
we're clear on that front.
What it does is it learns
routes dynamically.
It will configure
routing tables.
But then what it
does is it actually
pushes those routing tables
down to the VMs themselves.
So you can think of every VM in
a cloud environment as really
host routing, as opposed to,
say, a host in your data center
that, when it needs
to route a packet,
is going to push the
packet to the router.
The router's going to
look at RIBs and FIBs
and make a forwarding decision.
In this case, the
route table actually
lives on the VM itself.
So when the VM needs to
communicate to something,
be it another VM or maybe
your router that is on-prem,
it's actually going to route
directly to that IP address.
Because it has that routing
table on the VM itself.
One of the last things to
understand about the Cloud
Router is that it is a
Google-managed process.
So while you control
it and configure it,
it's actually a process
that we run on Google hosts.
And the big part to
understand about this
is if it fails for
any reason, Google
will re-spin up
that Cloud router
and re-establish
the environment.
There is nothing
that you have to do
in terms of your piece of that.
As long as you
configured it correctly,
in the event of failure,
Google will take
care of bringing it back up.
So when you're setting
up the Cloud Router
or when you're
setting up your VPC,
really, there's two routing
modes that you can enable.
So one is what we
call regional routing.
And the other's what
we call global routing.
So regional routing is where
when you put a Cloud Router
in a particular
region, it will only
learn subnets in that region.
So for example, if I
have an east, a central,
and a west region, and I have
regional routing modes enabled,
the Cloud Router, if
I put it in the west,
will only learn the subnets
that I put in the West Region.
And it will only advertise those
subnets out to either a VPN
that you've connected
it to or a dedicated
interconnect that
you're connecting to.
But it's only picking
up those subnets
that you configured
in the west region.
STEPHANIE WONG: I have
a couple of questions,
actually, going back to that.
The first question is I know
you talked about cloud routing
being the option
for Google Cloud,
but do we support any kind of
other routers, such as Cisco?
RYAN PRZYBYL: So
we're working on that.
The answer really is we
will support other routers
in the cloud
environment, but I'm
going to tell you why
I don't necessarily
think it's a good thing to do.
So because our Cloud
Router is heavily
integrated with
our platform, we're
able to take the data
plane off there, right?
So if you were to go drop
a Cisco, or a Juniper,
or other sort of cloud
router on the environment,
it's really creating a
single point of failure.
Because it's operating like
a very traditional router.
So you're creating
a choke point,
because all the packets have
to flow through that router.
Because it operates very much
like a traditional router
in your on-prem.
Packet flows to the router.
The router will look up, make
a routing decision, forward
things on.
Now, what we're doing
is we're working
to figure out how
do we integrate
that more with the platform so
that we can sort of eliminate
that and make the functionality
there more usable for customers
and not have to create that
choke-point or single point
of failure.
Because when that does fail,
because it is a data plane
device, your traffic
dies with it.
But as I talked about, when
the Cloud Router fails,
because it's only a
control plane device,
the data plane can
still function,
as long as you have some other
caveats, which I'll talk about
in a little bit.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great, thanks.
RYAN PRZYBYL: So let's
talk about global routing.
So we talked about
regional routing
where the router only
picks up regional subnets.
The other option to configure
in your VPC is global routing.
And just to mention again,
you set this at the VPC level,
but this is actually how
the cloud routers themselves
will operate within that VPC.
So global routing-- really,
it allows the router
to pick up all subnets.
So back to my example, if
you had an east, a central,
and a west region, and you
had subnets on all of them,
remember when I said
in the regional mode,
if you put the cloud
router on the west,
it would only pick
up the west subnet?
But if you're in global mode and
the cloud router's in the west,
it'll actually pick up
the subnets in the west,
the central, and the east.
So this really helps.
It's very powerful in terms of
when you're configuring VPCs,
as we talked about
in the first session.
Where you have a
global VPC construct,
and you have a
shared VPC construct,
and you don't want to be
putting cloud routers in all
of the regions all
around the world,
you can actually put cloud
routers in a couple of regions,
enable global routing, and
have it learning routes
throughout the entire VPC.
So it simplifies your
operational environment.
Now, there are
some caveats, which
I'll talk about when we
get to load balancing,
which is in a future session.
Because load balancers tend
to be regional resources.
There are some very
specific use cases
where you'd want to
use a regional routing
versus global
routing, because there
are such thing as regional
constructs in the VPC
environment.
STEPHANIE WONG: I was about
to follow up by asking,
we'll save it for the next one
as well, but any kind of use
cases for using one over the
other, regional versus global?
RYAN PRZYBYL: Yeah,
it really comes down
to the case for load balancers.
When you start to inject
internal load balancers
in the environment,
then you have
to be careful of
using global routing.
Because its a
regional construct,
you could, in essence,
create black holes
where you're trying
to route things
from one region to the other.
But because its a
regional construct--
it only lives in one region--
say you put the load
balancer in the central,
and you're trying to push
something from the west,
it may actually not
be able to reach it.
Because it's a
regional construct.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
this is something
you have to plan in advance.
RYAN PRZYBYL: Yeah, you
have to sort of understand
what components of GCP
you're going to be using.
That will influence what sort
of routing you want to use,
whether it's regional or global.
The other thing to talk about
is route priority, here.
So for those that are
familiar with BGP,
route priority is the equivalent
to the BGP metric MED, which
is multi exit discriminator.
So when you see route
priority in our console,
just think of MED.
That's how it will
manifest itself
when you go into
your routers on-prem,
and you look at the
route priorities.
So the standard default
route priority for all routes
is 1,000.
So if you don't change anything,
when you go into your router,
and you look at the MED
that your router is seeing,
it will see all of your subnets
that you're advertising.
It will see a route
priority of 1,000.
Now, that will change depending
on the configuration where
your interconnects are versus
where your subnets are.
So for example, let's go back
to the east, west, central sort
of environment.
If I have a subnet in the
west, and I'm advertising that
through an interconnect in the
east, what will actually happen
is the Cloud Router
knows that that's
something that lives
in the west region,
but that interconnect
is in the east region.
So it will artificially
inflate that route priority
by some value, which is based
on the RTT time from where
the interconnect was built
to where the subnet is built.
So for example, if you were
advertising two subnets--
one on the east, one on the
west-- to an interconnect
in the east, and you set
the route priority as 1,000
for both of them, and
then went into your router
and looked at the
metric for MED,
you would see that
the subnet in the east
had a route priority of 1,000,
which is what you configured.
But you'd see your
subnet in the west maybe
had a route priority of 1,700.
And you're asking well, where
is that other 700 coming from?
It's coming from
the intelligence
that the Google
Cloud Platform has in
knowing that subnet is
actually in the west.
So for example, if I had
an interconnect in the west
as well, and it was
advertising those same routes,
I would see the exact opposite.
The route in the west, when
you looked at your router,
would have a MED value of 1,000.
And the route in the
east would be 1,700.
So you can use route
priority where this really
comes into play, in terms
of traffic engineering
and how you want things
to flow in the network.
So a best practice is to always
have multiple interconnects
or multiple ways to connect
into your cloud environment.
So say you have an
interconnect and a VPN,
you could advertise all of your
routes across the interconnect.
And you could advertise all
of your routes across the VPN.
And the way that you would
make the VPN less preferred,
from a routing
standpoint, is you would
set the route priority higher.
So higher route
priority or higher MED
is always the least preferred.
For example, you could
advertise the default
1,000 out of the interconnect.
And then you could advertise
all the same routes with, say,
a 2,000 out of the VPN tunnel.
And that way, when your router
sees those two connections,
it's always going to
prefer the interconnect.
But in the event that
the interconnect fails,
it's automatically going
to fail over the VPN.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So there's no way
that Google would know
how to reconciliate
if you had something that
had the same priority?
RYAN PRZYBYL: Correct,
if you have something
that has the same
priority-- let's say
you have two
interconnects, and they're
both advertising the same
priority-- what will typically
happen is you're going ECMP
traffic across both of them.
So basically, you are load
balancing that traffic.
Because it sees two routes
with the same exact priority.
There's no preference
to one or the other.
It's going to use both paths.
So in this case, it could
use an interconnect and a VPN
or multiple interconnects.
So why is this stuff
really important to grasp
in terms of the Cloud Router?
I talk about failure impact.
When a cloud router
fails, like I said,
your data plane
can still function.
You just lost your
control plane.
The only thing is that
you can't update routes.
But you have to treat that a
little bit differently in terms
of your router that's on-prem.
So what you need to enable is
what we call graceful restart.
Graceful restart-- in
essence, what it is--
your on-prem router-- when it
sees the Cloud Router fails
and sees the BGP session drop,
what it's not going to do
is it's not going to
start stripping routes out
of the routing table.
It's going to say, hey, I
saw the Cloud Router fail.
I saw my BGP session fail.
But I'm just going
to play it cool.
I'm not going to mess
with any of the routing.
And what's happening in the
back side, is like I said,
this is a
Google-managed service.
So while Google is spinning
up that Cloud Router,
you're still pushing packets.
Because again, it's a control
plane only device on our side.
So you can still push
data plane packets.
And what happens is
after 60 seconds,
the Cloud Router is
going to come back up.
It's going to reestablish
BGP connectivity
with your router on-prem.
And then everything is
going to be fine again.
Now, the flip side
is if you didn't
have graceful restart
enabled, as soon
as the Cloud Router
failed, you'd
start tearing routes down.
Even though the data plane
is still up and functioning,
it would serve no
purpose to really start
tearing those routes down.
So that's a key piece
to really understand
the difference between,
like I talked about,
Cisco and Juniper or
the typical routers
that you have on-prem versus
how a Cloud Router works.
STEPHANIE WONG: We're seeing
a lot of value add here--
the cloud routing versus
kind of the traditional side,
where that would be more of
a single point of failure.
RYAN PRZYBYL: Yeah, and
even with the Cloud Routers,
we recommend running
multiple Cloud Routers
in the environment.
Our typical practice
is always run two.
And if you're enabled
with global routing,
and let's say you have a VPC--
let's go back to my east,
west, central example--
you could run one router on the
west, one router in the east,
and have global routing enabled.
It's learning all the routes.
Maybe you have an interconnect
in the east and west,
you're advertising all routes
across all interconnects.
That way if one Cloud
Router does fail,
you still have connectivity
to another Cloud Router.
Now again, we're going to reboot
the Cloud Router that failed.
But having two means
you're always going
to have that BGP connectivity.
You're always going
to able to route.
STEPHANIE WONG: So of
course, there's still
best practices that people
should be following--
setting up multiple
Cloud Routers,
everything that you
just talked about.
RYAN PRZYBYL: Typical
best practices
are use multiple Cloud
Routers, use global routing,
unless you have some
complex scenarios with ILBs
or various other things.
Those are two best practices.
And then on the on-prem
side, like I talked about,
set up graceful restart.
It's definitely a best practice.
So that when the
Cloud Router fails,
you don't start
stripping the routes out.
The other thing to understand
is a Cloud Router--
if you think about your
routers that you have on-prem,
it's a big box.
It's designed with very small
mean time between failure sort
of scenarios.
They're designed
never to go down.
So we're taking all
that intelligence
that you've put on
a router, and we're
putting on a very slim
little Google-managed host.
So these are not these
big robust chassis
that your router is.
So it will fail at a higher rate
than, say, an on-prem router.
Now, that shouldn't
scare anybody,
because I just talked about it.
The router can actually fail.
It does not disrupt traffic
in any way, shape, or form.
But you do have to understand
that the construct is
different.
So that's why you have
to have to start planning
for these failures
and engineer for them.
So that when they do
happen, it doesn't disrupt
the actual traffic flow.
So I talked a little about
using multiple Cloud Routers
for high availability.
We talked a little about
using route priority
for traffic engineering.
Again, this is where if you
have multiple interconnects,
you can be using the route
priority to dictate flow.
If I want to choose
interconnect A versus B,
a common scenario
customers may have is maybe
I have some very critical
infrastructure in the cloud.
I'm going to build a
VPN tunnel, but I'm only
going to advertise that
subnet over that tunnel.
So maybe I'm
advertising that subnet
over the interconnect with a
whole bunch of other subnets
at a route priority of 1,000.
And that's my normal path.
But I'm going to advertise
just that subnet, because it's
my critical subnet,
where I have a lot
of critical infrastructure
over a VPN tunnel.
I'm going to do it with,
say, a MED of 2,000.
So if I do fail, my
core critical traffic
will fail to the VPN.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right,
as a sort of a backup.
RYAN PRZYBYL: Yes.
Now, you could advertise
everything over that VPN, too.
But it just sort of depends
how you engineer this.
So let's talk about
advanced routes.
Advanced routes you can really
think of as static routes.
What you're really
doing is you're
configuring our
SDN control plane
and telling it how
to route things.
So a typical use case
for this is really
if you're trying to put,
say, a NAT gateway in place.
Or say you're trying to
run a third party firewall,
and you want to force
traffic to that.
So a good scenario was, I talked
about earlier, default routes.
So maybe you don't
want to default route
to Google's internet
gateway, but maybe you
want the default route to point
to a third party firewall.
You would use an advanced
route to do that.
You would basically say, I
want for my default route,
within this VPC,
the next hop to be
the IP address of the third
party firewall that I'm using.
So that's a very
common use case.
But you can sort
of control that.
And I'll take you through some
examples of how that's actually
used in practice.
When you're actually
configuring an advanced route,
there's really a couple Next
hops that you can specify.
1, you can specify
an internet gateway.
2, a VM instance.
3, an IP address.
Or 4, a VPN tunnel.
I'll show you how to configure
an advanced route when
I do a demo.
STEPHANIE WONG: Perfect.
RYAN PRZYBYL: So let's
talk about VPC peering.
VPC peering is one
way in which you can
get two VPCs to talk together.
The other way is
VPN, which we talked
about a little bit in the
first session that we did.
So the difference with the
VPC peering is it's binary.
Whereas when we
talk about VPN, you
can advertise certain subnets.
So if I have a VPN
between VPC A and B,
I could say I only want subnet
A to be advertised across that.
With VPC peering, it's binary.
So all subnets in VPC
A will get advertised
to all subnets in VPC
B. So if you recall,
I talked about
preprogrammed routes
when we first started
the conversation.
Basically, what
you're doing is taking
all those preprogrammed
routes on A,
and you're programming
them into B.
You're taking all the
preprogrammed routes in B
and programming into A.
That's really what you're
doing when you do VPC peering.
Another way to think
about it is you're
sort of smashing two VPCs
together to make one VPC.
Now, the one
fundamental difference
is security policies.
And we'll talk a bit more
about security and firewalls
in the next session.
But the key thing to
understand about VPC peering
is the security policies
are done at the VPC level.
So even though you smash
two VPCs together and make
one logical VPC in terms of
the pre-configured routes,
you still actually have two
separate security policies.
So I've had customers
call me and say, hey,
I've done VPC peering.
I've put these
two VPCs together,
but I can't actually
see traffic.
Traffic won't route
back and forth.
And typically it's because
you have two separate security
policies, and the
policies are written such
that you're not allowing
traffic from the other VPC.
So a lot of times, if
you do VPC peering,
and things aren't working
as you expect them to,
go and check the
firewall policies
and the security policies
that you applied to both VPCs.
STEPHANIE WONG: This also
makes me kind of think
about can you have overlapping
IP ranges or subnet IP ranges?
RYAN PRZYBYL: No.
So when you peer
two VPCs together,
you cannot have overlapping IPs,
because it wouldn't know how
to route them.
It would say, hey.
When it has to make
a routing decision,
it says, hey, I
see this IP here,
and I don't know what to do.
So actually, if you have
two overlapping subnets,
and you try to peer two VPCs,
it actually does that check
on the backside
and will tell you
that you can't peer
those two VPCs together.
So if this is something that
you're planning on using,
you need to consider that in
terms of your IP allocations
and your subnet setups.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
when you go to deploy,
it will actually kind of
prohibit you from deploying
if it realizes that there's--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RYAN PRZYBYL: Correct, so you'll
build two VPCs separately.
And then you'll say,
I want to peer them.
And you have to be
peering on both sides.
So this can be
used, for example,
to interconnect a VPC
that you own with a VPC
maybe a customer
organization owns.
So what you don't
want to do is you
don't want to just
be able to enable
VPC peering to another VPC.
It's sort of like a VPN
configuration in terms
of you've got to configure
the gateway on one side
and the gateway on the other.
When you do VPC
peering, you have
to configure it on your side.
And you have to configure
it on the other side.
And both sides have to be
set up to sort of match.
And then it will allow
the peering to happen.
A few things to be
cognisant about,
there's quotas around this.
So a common architecture
might be a hub
and spoke sort of architecture.
So you have your hub, and
you have maybe five spokes.
As long as the total number of
VMs in that peering arrangement
is not over 15,500, you're OK.
If you go to exceed
15,500, it's not
going to allow you to
setup that peering session.
The other thing to
understand is you
can have 25 peered networks.
So if we have a hub
and spoke environment,
you can think of
I've got one hub.
I can have 24 spokes as long
as the total number of VMs
are also under 15,500.
So one last thing
to understand there
is the transitive nature, or
non-transitive nature really,
of peering.
So what I really mean by that
is if you have VPC A, VPC
B, and VPC C, and A is peered
with B, and B is peered with C,
a lot of customers
ask can A get to C.
And the answer is no, because
it's non transitive in nature.
So if you want A to get to C,
you'd have to peer A and C.
But A cannot transit
B to get to C.
So that's another key
thing to understand.
STEPHANIE WONG: Do you
know the philosophy
behind why Google wanted
to design it that way?
RYAN PRZYBYL: It's
really just to facilitate
interacting with
other VPCs and being
able to take all those
pre-configured routes,
and being able to
push them other places
without having to
use a VPN tunnel.
Like if you just want to say,
I want all the subnets here
to talk to all the subnets
here, but I've built them
into two separate
VPCs, it allows
you to, in one way, like I
said, merge them into one VPC,
yet still maintain separate
security policies, too.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, so for
that that use case especially?
RYAN PRZYBYL: Yeah,
so you may have
a VPC that is sensitive
information that you want
access, but you want to have
a very specific security
policy for it.
That would be one example.
Or like I said, if you're
interfacing with a customer
organization.
So maybe you're a supplier,
and you have a vendor
that you interact with.
Well, you don't want to just
have one VPC with one company
or the other managing it, right?
You want to have your
own security policy.
They want to have their
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
RYAN PRZYBYL: So I'm going to
take you through a reference
architecture now.
This sort of shows how all
of this works together.
So what I've created
here is three VPCs.
So I have a standard
VPC on the left.
I have a shared VPC
in the top middle.
And then I have another
shared VPC in the lower right.
And then I've put subnets
in there that you can see.
So 10.1 is in the standard VPC.
10.0 is actually coming
from an on-prem environment.
10.2 is on the shared
VPC in the middle.
And 10.3 is in the
shared VPC down
in the lower right-hand corner.
So I want to interconnect a
bunch of this stuff together.
So the first thing I'm
going to talk through
is the standard VPC connecting
it to the on-prem environment.
So in this case, I'm putting
two Cloud Routers in place,
and I've built
two interconnects.
So you can see the dedicated
interconnect in the east
and the central region.
So what those Cloud
Routers are going to do
is they're going to learn
all the routes that I have
programmed in the standard VPC.
And they're going to
advertise them via BGP
to the on-prem environment.
And that's going to allow
the on-prem environment
to talk to the standard VPC.
So that's the first thing I did.
The second thing is I
want to peer two of these.
So if I take the
shared VPC number two,
I'm going to peer that
with standard VPC.
So that allows, again,
standard VPC and shared VPC
to communicate together via
that peering relationship.
So what I have here
is I have this--
if you look at the bottom,
it says programmed routes.
So in standard VPC, I'm going
to now have programmed routes.
And again, these
are routes that I
talked about in the very first
slide that you can't change.
Because I set this
peering relationship up,
I'm going to have
programmed routes for 10.3
in that standard VPC.
And in the shared VPC, I'm
going to have programmed
routes for 10.1 subnets or the
10.1.1 and the 10.1.2 subnet,
because those were
the subnets that I
created with the standard VPC.
And again, when you
peer the two together,
it's going to preprogram
all those subnets
into each of them.
So that's what that
programmed route section is.
So the shared VPC number 1--
in this case, the padlocks
represent a third party
firewall device.
So this is a
scenario maybe that's
a financier VPC or
something, when I want
to limit connectivity to it.
So what that device is
doing is it's actually
sitting with one
NIC in standard VPC
and one NIC in the shared VPC.
So in the standard VPC, I
have the IP of 10.1.1.1.
That's the NIC that's
sitting in the standard VPC.
And 10.2.1.1 is the NIC that's
sitting in the shared VPC.
So now, I want to be able to
route traffic back and forth.
So I talked about
advanced routes.
So let's take the
shared VPC number 1.
So in this case, I want
to be able to route
traffic from the
shared VPC number
1 back to the standard VPC.
So in this case, I'm putting
an advanced route in there
for 10.0.1, which is really
the subnet in the data center.
So I'm saying all
of that subnet,
you're telling
shared VPC it exists.
But it exists somewhere else.
And the next hop to get
to it is the firewall.
So that's that 10.2.1.1.
So what I'm telling
it is for 10.0.1.0,
that whole subnet, if you
need to get there, which
is the on-prem environment,
go to 10.2.1.1,
which is the NIC that
sits in that VPC.
I'm also doing the same
thing on the other side.
In the standard
VPC, I'm configuring
another advanced route.
In this case, the Cloud
Routers are picking up
this advanced route and they're
advertising it to the on-prem.
So the on-prem knows I
can get to 10.2 subnet.
But when it comes
into the standard VPC,
it's going to say,
oh, 10.2 doesn't
live in the standard VPC.
It lives in the shared VPC.
And for me to get
to 10.2, I need
to go to a next hop of 10.1.1.1.
So this gets a little
complex, but it shows you
how you can use VPC peering
in terms of the shared
VPC at the bottom, how you
get preprogrammed routes
and how they
propagate, but also how
you can inject a third
party firewall in the mix
and then configure advanced
routes to force things
through the firewall, where you
then implement your security
policy.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right, so
just to reiterate again,
GCP to GCP peering would be
using preprogrammed routes.
Do peering for
different subnets.
Meanwhile, you would
use advanced routes
to force traffic to the
next hop, which might exist
in a third-party firewall.
RYAN PRZYBYL: Yeah, it's
usually a third party
device of some sort.
So it could be a firewall.
It could be a NAT gateway
that you've configured.
But you want to force traffic
to a particular device.
So you're telling it.
Another example might be--
let's say that firewall
is the firewall
that I've used to
connect to the internet.
So I could build a default
route in shared VPC number 1.
Say for all the zeros, go
to the interface 10.2.1.1.
And that would push anything
that's not part of your 10.
private space to the firewall.
The firewall would
then do NAT-ing on it
and be able to push
it, externally,
out to the internet.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK, understood.
RYAN PRZYBYL: That's
just another sort
of common use case for this.
Like I said, this does
get a little complex.
So it's a little bit deeper
of a topic to understand.
But it just goes to show that
when you're routing in cloud,
there are lots of
ways to do this.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
if they're trying
to map out what they're
doing on premise,
then the possibilities are
still here in the cloud.
You can actually kind of
map it out in some way.
RYAN PRZYBYL: Exactly, there's
lots of ways to do this.
Like I said, you can use
VPN tunnels versus VPN
peering or versus VPC peering.
Like we talked about, peering
is going to be binary.
So it's in all subnets
to all subnets--
versus if you wanted one
subnet to one subnet,
you'd use a VPN tunnel
to connect them, right?
So again, anything you can
generally do in on-prem,
you can find a way to do
in the cloud environment.
It's just you have to understand
the complexities of routing
and how it works, and
how a Cloud Router works,
and how routes get
picked up and cascade.
STEPHANIE WONG: How
they differ, as well.
RYAN PRZYBYL: So I'm going
to take you to a demo
and show you how this
stuff works in the portal.
So what I've
configured here is I've
configured a demo environment.
I'll make it a little
bigger so we can see it.
So in this demo
environment, I've
created two VPCs, Cloud OnAir
102 and Cloud OnAir 102 peering
VPC.
So I'm going to show you how
the VPC peering routes manifest.
And then, in the first VPC, I
have created two subnets, one
in US central, one in US east.
And that's 10.1 and 10.2.
In the peering VPC, I've
created a subnet 10.3.
So that's our standard setup.
Now, I'm going to take
you through the routes,
so you can actually see
how these routes manifest.
So when you're looking at
this in the Google portal,
you can understand
what you're looking at.
So I'm going to go over here.
I'm going to go down to routes.
So this is the first page
when you come into the routes
piece of things.
It's showing you all
of the routes, here.
So you can see a number
of these default routes.
These are the routes
I was telling you
that are preprogrammed.
So these first 1, 2, 3, 4, 5--
we've got 5 or six routes here
that are default routes.
You can't change these.
And then it's
showing you we've got
some peering routes in here.
And then, I actually have
a Cloud Router created
that is actually talking to a
router I've configured off-site
from this.
And I've set that router to
advertise some subnets down
here.
So the first page, it
gives you the total view
of all of your outs, which,
for this simple environment,
is very easy to look at.
But I've seen customers
that literally
have 10 pages of this.
So it's a little more
complex to look at.
So if you want to
look at what you're
learning from a
dynamic perspective--
so you can see these
192.168 blocks,
when I clicked on
the dynamic tab,
this is what I'm learning
from the Cloud Router.
So again, I configured
a router outside
of the cloud
environment, and I told
it to advertise these routes.
And I didn't put
any MED on there.
So it's set with a
MED of 0, effectively.
And that's why it's showing
up as route priority of 0
on this side.
And then the next
top IP address--
this is actually the IP
address of the off-site router
that I configured.
So as I said, when you
look at a VM level,
you're going to see these
routes get programmed in there--
those 192.168 routes.
And if they had to route,
they would build an IP packet
with the destination
of 169.254.40.50.
And it would route directly
to that off-prem router
that I've configured.
The other part is if you
can click on peering,
this is going to show you
all of the routes you're
learning via VPC peering.
So again, you can look at all
the routes in this first tab,
but it's going to get
very big and very complex
if you're building any
sort of real environment.
So sometimes, it's easier to
look at your default routes,
here.
But again, you
can't change those.
And then if you want
to look at the routes
that you're learning, you
click on the dynamic tab.
If you want to look at
your peering routes,
you'd click on the peering tab.
So that's how your
routes show up in here.
So create route-- this is
basically the advanced route
function I was talking about.
So if I click on
that, it's going
to take me into the ability
to create the route.
So I'm going to give
the route a name.
I'm going to tell it what
network I want it to live in.
I'm going to prescribe an IP
range for it, a simple route
priority, just like I do
for all normal routes.
And then, as I was
saying, you can basically
point it to different things.
So this is like saying if you're
going to point to a firewall--
if you're going to
point to a VPN tunnel,
you would select what you
want to point that route to.
So that's how you
configure it here.
And then you just click Create.
It'll create that route.
So in that VPC, that
route will then live.
And all the VMs will get
programmed with that route.
So like I said, it could
be a default route.
It could be a lot
of different things.
STEPHANIE WONG: Can you do all
of this in the Cloud Shell or--
RYAN PRZYBYL: You can.
I could do this in
Cloud Shell, but you
wouldn't want to sit here and
watch me type everything out.
Sometimes, it's easier
to do it in the console.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, absolutely.
RYAN PRZYBYL: So lastly,
I want to show how easy it
is to configure a Cloud Router.
Because they are
very, very simple.
People think of
configuring a router--
they think I'm
going to configure
my Cisco or Juniper, which can
be a very complex thing to do.
In this case, it's
actually very simple.
So this is the Cloud Router
I've actually stood up.
As I said, I have a Cloud
Router in this environment.
I'm learning routes from another
router that I've configured.
So you can see I've got an
up BGP session right here.
But what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create another router.
So in this case, let's
just give it a name.
We'll just call it Test 1.
I have to drop it
in a particular VPC.
I could drop it in
a region as I said.
If you're using
regional or global,
this could be important.
So I'm going to drop
this in US central 1.
And then I have to tell
it what ASN number is
this representing.
So the cloud order I configured
in here before was 65001.
So to be consistent, I'm going
to put the same thing in here.
I'm going to click Create.
And it's going to go, and it's
going to create a Cloud Router.
So this is a cloud.
It's literally that simple to
create the actual Cloud Router.
Now, I have to
attach it to things.
So I have to attach
it to a VPN, or I
have to attach it
to an interconnect
or various other things.
So that would be
the next step here.
And then once you
have it attached,
then you're going
to bring BGP up.
So then you can start
advertising routes.
So really, there's three steps.
There's creating Cloud
Router, attaching it
to something like a
tunnel or an interconnect,
and then establishing
your BGP connectivity
and then going back to the
routes menu that I showed you
and verifying that your
routes are flowing.
STEPHANIE WONG: So you might
have some configuration
that you need to do back on
your on premise network--
RYAN PRZYBYL: Yeah, you're
going to have to configure
your on-prem router.
So if you set this up to,
say, connect to a VPN tunnel,
and that VPN tunnel
terminates on-prem,
you're going to have to
configure your Cloud Router.
You're going to configure
your VPN gateway.
You're going to reconfigure your
on-prem router, and your VPN
gateway, and your
on-prem environment,
just like you would in
the cloud environment.
Once everything is
configured on both sides,
then you'll see the BGP session
come up like I have here.
This green check is
what you're looking for.
So that's it.
That's pretty much a
high level overview
of routing in GCP
and VPC peering.
So let's go take some questions.
STEPHANIE WONG: We'll
be back in just a minute
for some questions.
All right, thanks so much
for all of your questions.
Here we have a handful.
I'll go ahead and read them out.
The first one is, is the
Cloud Router operating
and, or, configurable
at layer 2 or 3?
RYAN PRZYBYL: So
the Cloud Router
itself is a layer 3 device.
It operates just like
a traditional router.
Depending on the
interconnect type--
so if you're using a dedicated
interconnect or a partner
interconnect, that's really
a layer 2 interconnect.
We are going to configure
the interconnect.
And then, what
you're going to do
is you're going to
build a VLAN attachment.
So that's your layer 2 element.
And what you do is
you attach the VLAN
off of the interconnect
to the Cloud Router.
But the actual configuring,
in terms of the Cloud Router,
it's actually operating
only at a layer 3 level.
It's really just an
IP routing device.
Like I said, it's
really a BGP speaker.
That's really what it is.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great, so
next question is, can you
apply instance and route
tags to route traffic
to specific instances?
RYAN PRZYBYL: So you can.
So there's a concept of
tags, where you can apply--
so say I create a route.
And I want to route to only
be applied to certain VMs.
When you create the
route you could say,
I only want this route
to live on certain VMs.
And you would do that
by specifying a tag.
So you could say,
I want this route.
So maybe it's a
default route you
don't want to live everywhere
or some other specific route.
You would build
that route, and you
would say I want it to live on
VMs that have the right tag.
And then when you create
the VMs, you create the VM
and put the red tag on it.
And then what will happen
is it'll import that route
into that particular VM.
So you could have routes that
live on some VMs and not others
by using tags.
STEPHANIE WONG: So you
can map using tags.
Next question is,
how do you ensure
you can maintain
routing locality
to keep the next hop from
the same region or zone?
RYAN PRZYBYL: So
routing locality--
it's sort of a complex
piece of the puzzle.
So this is like where is your
interconnect versus where
are your subnets.
This gets into
the topic of where
do you put your ILBs
and things like that.
So it's really about
understanding where you've
provisioned things and then
setting up the routes to route
appropriately to them.
So for example, if I have
an interconnect in the east,
and I only want the
subnets in my east region
to flow through
that interconnect,
I probably wouldn't
use global routing.
I might just use
regional routing
and only advertise the subnets
east of the interconnect
in the east.
And maybe I do the
same thing in the west.
I have a Cloud Router in the
west with an interconnect
in the west, and
then I only want
those routes to be advertised
to that interconnect.
So that what you're
maintaining locality
where the interconnect is
in the same region where
the subnets are, versus if
you're using global routing,
like I explained before.
You could actually advertise
your east subnets to the west.
But they're going have
an inflated MED, because
of the RTT distance that we're
going to compute for you.
So there are ways to do it.
A lot of times, like I
said, the biggest thing
you have to be
concerned about here
is when you start to
put ILBs in the mix.
Because then global routing
can really bite you.
You want to make
sure you understand
the concept of locality.
So where the
interconnect's coming in,
the ILB has to be
in the same region.
If you have an
interconnect in the west
and an ILB in the
central region,
the interconnect
lives in the west.
And the ILB lives in
the central region.
And they can't
talk to each other.
So if you have global
routing, and you're
advertising a subnet
on the central
through the interconnect
in the west,
it's actually going
to come in the west.
But it can't
actually hit the ILB.
STEPHANIE WONG: I see.
RYAN PRZYBYL: So that's
where this gets more complex.
STEPHANIE WONG: So there's
three factors-- load balancers,
keeping it as a
regional Cloud Router,
and advertising the
appropriate subnets.
RYAN PRZYBYL: Yeah, how you
want to advertise the subnets.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great, next
question is, are firewall rules
imported into a peered network?
RYAN PRZYBYL: So no.
So when you do VPC
peering, as I mentioned,
the firewall rules
and the policies
are designed separately.
So VPC A has its own set of
security policies and rules.
VPC has its own
policies and rules.
So let's say, for example, I
have 10.1 in VPC A and 10.2
in VPC B. I may have firewall
rules that allow 10.2 to talk
to a whole bunch of stuff.
And I may have firewall rules in
the VPC A that lock down 10.1.
Those rules I've written do
not go across with peering.
So you still have to configure
the security policies
independently.
And you have to enable that
peering flow, potentially.
It depends what your
policy really is.
If you have your policy
locked down really tight,
you could peer two things, and
actually, nothing could happen.
If you have a very
loose policy, where
you're sort of letting any
VM talk to any VM with, say,
a 10. address, then
chances are you're
not going to have any issues.
STEPHANIE WONG: It
depends if they clash.
RYAN PRZYBYL: But to answer
the direct question, no.
The rules that you write in
policy A when you do peering
do not go over to VPC B.
STEPHANIE WONG: Got it.
And the last one
is, can an instance
have more than one network
interface with each interface
in different VPC networks?
Sorry, say that again.
RYAN PRZYBYL: So this
was a good example.
This was the third
party firewall
that I configured
in that use-case.
So that was an underlying VM
running a third party firewall
appliance on top of it.
And it had one NIC
sitting in the VPC
on the left and one NIC sitting
in the VPC on the right.
So you can absolutely do that.
You actually have eight
NICs to play with.
Now, one NIC can
only sit in one VPC.
So if I have a VM, and
there's eight NICs on it,
only one of those NICs can live
in VPC A. One of those NICs
can live in VPC B. I
can basically connect it
to eight different VPCs.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
that's the instance level.
But one VM could have
multiple networking--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RYAN PRZYBYL: Correct,
one VM is going
to have eight
effective NICs on it.
STEPHANIE WONG: Wow, that really
expands the use-case, I think,
there.
So I think that's
all the time we have.
Thank you so much, everyone,
for joining us today.
Please stay tuned
for the next session,
which is how App Maker can
enhance the G Suite experience.
Thank you so much, Ryan.
RYAN PRZYBYL: You're welcome.
STEPHANIE WONG: We'll see you
next time for Network 103.
[MUSIC PLAYING]